[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
all right
folks up I made a statement earlier to
probably thios repeating while you're
all welcome to sit here and observe
no one should interfere or interrupt
these pursuits if you do you risk being
held in contempt which carries a fine or
incarceration in some cases or certainly
being removed from the courtroom so by
all means sit and observe but but do not
interrupt these proceedings and with
respect to the press we have the pool
cameras up here and other members of the
press if you have your laptop so
telephones you can you can communicate
with them and of course of doing your
job you cannot take pictures or record
anyone violates these requirements your
phone can be taken from you and as I
said likewise you're gonna be hungry
attempt so I don't anticipate anybody
will act contrary to my instruction
you won't and I thank you in advance for
your consideration okay mister follow
this complaints tried to assess in the
time of the intrepid on July 8 2016 did
commit indecent that's all better than
first and 14 or over sir if Europe you
could charge another offense well this
matter is open you could be held for a
90 days mr. da requests beyond the bill
warning and beyond the bail morning Your
Honor the Commonwealth is requesting
that mr. Spacey be ordered to stay away
and have no contact with a named victim
and his family
all right certainly the court will
impose those conditions anything
additional no judge okay all right so no
no no requests in terms of movement
staying within the United States as
required by the court judge and as
report required by the probation
department our only request simply
specifically is the stay away okay all
right sir up till the new information
you'll sign those conditions required to
stay Wayne have no contact direct or
indirect with the alleged victim all
right I know there was a motion file to
buy a defense and occasion to look at it
we reviewed him yesterday okay
briefly judge regarding the motions to
preserve we agree that anything that is
currently in our custody and control we
have to preserve we will preserve and we
will turnover and discovery sure as it
relates to the motion to preserve itself
we're suggesting at this point that the
scope that is being requested by counsel
is overly broad it's asking for July 7th
an July 8th of 2016 but all the way up
to the present
we suggest that based on what's been
filed up to the present is overly broad
the affidavits and the motion suggest
that mr. little and his girlfriend or
another individual or texting
contemporaneously on the 7th into the
8th and then it says by providing this
other information we'll likely see that
something happened or that he talked
about it further but there's no basis
for that information within the motion
of reserve we would suggest that it's a
fishing expedition at this point and
that the motion should be narrowed at
least to the 7th and 8th of July of 2016
it's a fair point mr. Jackson I miss
Polly I was gonna respond but feel free
all we have to respond I'll text on
pasteurization sure your honor I don't
believe at this point that we need to
talk about the scope that's something in
terms of a subpoena or what those
individuals might require a discussion
or some litigation about the scope all
I'm asking at this point is that we
preserve it in other words this is data
that we believe is not only potentially
exculpatory but likely the disculpa
tourism mr. Spacek I simply don't want
to see any of that data deleted
destroyed even inadvertently or in other
words in any other way manipulated I
don't think it's a burden at all on the
Commonwealth nor on the two individuals
names in motion indeed and the
complaining witness to simply say I'm
ordering you not to destroy anything so
that mr. Jackson miss bolero the
Commonwealth can litigate in front of
the court at some point whether
there is exculpatory information that
leads all the way up to today in other
words all I'm asking for is just to put
up a bubble around that data so it
doesn't get the story I'm not saying I
get it yet I just don't want to destroy
it yet we can only control judge at this
point what's in the care custody and
control the Commonwealth but as far as
information that would be contained
within the specific service providers of
these individual cell phone carriers
well that's different we have no control
over that judge so we would suggest that
as far as the preservation goes rather
it be to the individuals directly or to
the providers that it be limited at this
point to the 7th and the 8th until more
information can be provided as to why it
might likely be exculpatory versus a
fishing expedition right I haven't seen
any of the in the police report so I
don't know what except for you graphic
David I don't know what information that
you request upon and I do think that the
7th an age appropriate the time span to
to preserve the evidence but I
understand that even if the motion is
allowed it can be modified down the road
it can be tightened up and so I'm
inclined to allow the motion I don't
know that I'm going to do it all the way
up until look you know from from the 7th
and 8th though and I may give you a
maybe six months worth of preservation
but I don't know that I'm gonna require
that everything be preserved certainly
this point that would be satisfactory
six months wasn't part of the
preservation I think is better than
and I'm certainly willing to accommodate
the Commonwealth and of course that work
on that so so from from was it July 7
July 7 and 8 of G 2016 okay and six
months thereafter all right six months
thereafter promotion will be allowed at
least it'll be a requirement that that
these cell phones and I think the cloud
and then some passwords etcetera that
all be preserved as I say that's subject
to further modification that one way or
the other depending on what is
discovered during the course of this
matter so all right we have a further
date that gents and ladies that we
haven't discussed one yet counsel sure
you can be seated
mr. Jackson is a little prototype VJ are
you going to require my appearance
returns from someone's of my office are
you are you are you been already I know
you you came in so that he could enter
the product but I do have a notice of
appearance on the file and mr. Jackson
his father so your appearance is already
in
Your Honor if it pleases the poor
Council on have discussed informally a
date of the 4th of March which is a
Monday I understand that's most
convenient to the court yeah that's
that's right that's like Georgia week is
in February so so my explore the
property work and council oh and I also
discussed off the record and I would ask
to the courts getting some of this hands
no objection the Commonwealth has no
objection to mr. spacely not making that
appearance I can make that up here on
his behalf along with miss Valero if
need be without him having to to be
there on that day that's fine his
appearance can be waived
however he should be the rule requires
that he be available so he should at
least be on the other end of the phone
if there's some reason that absolutes
that we contacted absolutely but his
appearance can be waived
okay thank you
[Music]
Ilse you need additional folks I don't
think so your honor
no all right thank you all for your help
I'm gonna step off and then you people
can break down their equipment and those
connected with the case thank you very
much
Oh
she's gonna come out behind us
right
drinking
kind of yeah
barbarous detective
scram
straight ahead
Hey
yeah
yeah
because you say here
[Music]
yeah
you